كانت آبي براي طفلة صغيرة تتمتع بصحة جيدة في
تامبا فلوريدا عندما قالت بعد شهر من
عيد ميلادها التاسع ،
إنها تشعر وكأن هناك سكاكين في عظامي
بعد أن أجرى طبيب الأطفال بعض الاختبارات ،
مكالمة هاتفية مع والديها لورا ومايك
هناك سرير في انتظارها  في
وحدة أورام الأطفال في سانت جو ، قم بتعبئة خطة حقيبة
للبقاء هناك على الفور
كانت آبي تعاني من سرطان الدم الليمفاوي الحاد
لإنقاذ حياتها ، وستحتاج إلى
نظام صارم من العلاج الكيميائي
بما في ذلك عقار يسمى irwinase
ولكن بعد بضعة أشهر من العلاج
قيل لنا
حسنًا أن لديك  بالعودة إلى المنزل ، لا يمكنك الحصول على
هذا الدواء اليوم ، إنه نقص
أرادت آبي الإجابات التي كانت تعلم أنها بحاجة
إلى تناول كل أدويتها ،
ما يحدث الآن
هل هذا يعني أنني
أموت عندما انطلقت لورا في العمل
لتجميع مجموعة من الأصدقاء تسمى
ملائكة آبي  لقد أعدت قائمة
بمستشفيات الأطفال في الولايات المتحدة ، وقد
شارك الجميع لإجراء مكالمات هاتفية
بعد بضع ساعات فقط ، وقد
مررنا بها ونعرفها  د بعض
الأدوية التي اتصل بها أحد أصدقائي
خلال الأشهر التسعة التالية ، احتاجت لورا
للتدخل مرة أخرى للحصول على عقارين آخرين
لم يتمكن المستشفى من العثور عليه بسبب
النقص الذي لم أفكر فيه مرة واحدة في
أنني سأضطر أيضًا إلى
التنقل في أكبر  سلسلة التوريد العالمية في
العالم من أجل إبقائها على قيد الحياة لورا
هي أستاذة في كلية إدارة الأعمال ولذا
كانت لديها المهارات اللازمة للقيام بذلك لكنها كانت
تعلم أن العائلات الأخرى لم تكن محظوظة جدًا لدرجة
أنها تطاردني حقًا دراسة العام الماضي
أظهرت أن من أصل 19 أساسيًا  عوامل
لعلاج السرطان لدى الأطفال 74 في المائة
عانوا من نقص واحد أو أكثر منذ عام
2016. يقول
طبيب أورام الأطفال الدكتور أورام أنجورو
إن هناك عدة أسباب لهذا
النقص ، بما في ذلك عندما تنظر إلى
الأدوية التي تعاني من نقص في
الإمداد فهي ليست
أدوية Blockbuster هم  ليست
الأدوية التي تجني منها شركات الأدوية أرباحًا ضخمة ،
لذلك أخذت لورا الأمور بين
يديها وتشكل الملائكة من أجل التغيير
برفع حوالي نصف ميل  تقول إنها
في أقل من ثلاث سنوات لدفع
أموال لمصنع أدوية صغير لصنع
الأدوية الأساسية وتقديمها إلى أي
مستشفى يحتاجها منذ مايو / أيار
، تم الوصول إليها أكثر من نصف
مليون مرة للمرضى في جميع
أنحاء الولايات المتحدة.  من الخبراء ، ما عليك سوى
إلقاء نظرة على ما
أنجزته مؤسستها في السنوات القليلة الماضية ،
وأعتقد أنها تتحدث عن نفسها وهناك
ما يمكن قوله حول هذا القول المأثور ،
ليس لدى الجحيم غضب مثل الدب الغاضب ،
هذه الأم التي تتنقل في
سلسلة التوريد العالمية للأطفال جميعًا  حول
البلاد مع
الإبلاغ عن السرطان إليزابيث كوهين CNN